wake up in the morning feeling like
Steve Jobs grabbed my macbook I'm out
the door I'm gonna hit this city before
i leave brush my teeth with an iphone
app cause if you didn't know there is an
app for that
I'm talking all my toes so even all the
close close we close up the phones
phones download and clean on my mp3
cheese wanna become the mayor don't make
it to the battery
Oh
the world except my bad in life there's
only one collinear and I've already here
and now the dudes are lining up cause
they hear I got power but I keep him to
the curb unless they're at 10% I'm
talking everybody get in charge charge
if it gets you close close now now I'm
trying to kick me out or the pony shut
me down down wholly shut me down down
po-po shut me
you charge me up you brought me down my
heart it pounds with every charge with
my
Oh
you judge me
I won't start till I plug it in don't
stop
I
yeah